do I need any weird audio stuff on
discord oh you need those sound effects
that's it I'm just gonna use the game
audio correct yes really hurts my face
to do that what are you doing don't do
that
you said dildo sound effects private
match what do we want to do blood and
gold or Megalodon hunt okay that sounds
cool no BOTS or yes bots let's just do
us see how this goes I don't know how
this is gonna go but maybe it's gonna go
so let's find a little private server
I think Megalodon hunt if one of us is a
Megalodon oh yeah no that's how I've
never played it but one person is the
Megalodon we have to kill it and become
the Megalodon yeah yeah well this I know
right oh that's not good is it
uncontrolled no it's not swimming oh it
is swimming I'm shooting it oh my god
I'm going for it guys you're going for
you it's just floating what what is this
oh hey look some treasure we can't
gather yeah we can yeah no you can
gather
Oh [ __ ] my murdering you sufficiently
oh wait who became who became the mega
lady no don't do it I definitely didn't
already I just no one no one is hitting
you you just be quiet you oh god damn it
Bob are you okay I'm fine I did it I did
the shark now shark to be a shark up on
the streets
ha so where can we see where he is or
yeah there's like a red glow well that's
not fair oh yeah oh it's not that's why
whatever I spawned in being shot at I
was already bitter oh my god I got
doubles nice [ __ ]
I see you kill em I had two guns and
everything go I do keep what's doing
that I'm gonna eat some seals who's
doing that whoa-oh
who's fighting I was be eating seals
being a nice little Megalodon and you
guys you guys are [ __ ] you know
little guy come at me [ __ ] come
out to me [ __ ]
what is that might as there is your
fault that little pizza pie I think
that's going down
that's your health is there a way for us
to buy gear or some thoughts yeah you
the more treasure you gather the more
gear you get upgrade it did Sidon that
means what are we where do we upgrade it
though it automatically happens when you
respawn I think cuz I have a better gun
and I do not recall ever oh yeah it
automatically happens I just got guns
without even dying nice no it's not
yeah just gotta get good son got a
giggity good get good [ __ ] whoa whoa
[ __ ] prepare to get [ __ ] you better not
kill me I'm just gathering I'm just
gathering gold my dead shark friends
just floating here
my ancestors god damnit where are you
you're so small ah I see you see ya
gotta go bye ah jeez added being shark
you know where I where it's fine this is
fine ah ha ha ha I got it I got a thrash
him I took it who did that who is doing
[ __ ] [ __ ] you mom oh I see who doing
[Laughter]
yes please
I like the blood mark is no suck it at
this game I've just been playing it for
like an hour maybe but you know I've
never been the shark before so maybe you
guys just our balls ass Wow I mean
you're right Wow wait where is he Korey
I'll save you ah crap [ __ ] are you
alright buddy no no wait Bob mark Bob
killed me after he killed all you guys
you know saving you why the shirt was
back at full health I was very upset I'm
not doing anything just leave me alone
stop getting sales I'm just your
friendly neighborhood Megalodon this is
fine Oh would you [ __ ] stop it
how's that how's that feel huh where'd
you go how's that feel
[Music]
[Laughter]
Wow you didn't Wow you really didn't
terrible oh boy it's okay it's really
hard to kill people as an overpowered
Megalodon infinitely powerful shark much
faster than everyone else's game
[Music]